Phil.
PHIL: Hey.
MIKE: Man, you got the Matchless
bobber thing going on here.
Oh, that is cool.
- How you doing, buddy?
- OK.
- Hey, I'm Mike.
- Hey, Mike.
How are you?
You talked to
Dani on the phone?
- Yeah, I did.
- Yeah, this is Frank.
Phil, how you doing?
I'm Frank.
- Hey, Frank.
- Nice to meet you.
Pleasure.
- This is cool.
What is this, '40s?
This is a 1947.
You know, Brando had
a Matchless scrambler.
Not in "The Wild One."
In "The Wild One,"
he rode a Triumph.
FRANK: Is this
something you'd sell?
PHIL: Yep.
FRANK: So, you know, I'm
checking out the motorcycle
a little bit, and I want
to see if the motor's free,
so I kick through.
Motor's free, sounds a little
gravelly in there, you know?
When bikes sit, all the oil
goes down into the crankcase,
so it might need a
little top-end oil,
make it a little smoothed out.
It's just this kind of
bike needs to be run.
Battery put in it, fresh
gas, throttle cable
fixed, and try to start it.
Well, what would you
have to have for it?
I was thinking maybe 8.
$8,000?
That's about a $4,500
bike, if it's running.
I appreciate you putting a
price on it, but at $8,000,
I'm probably not a player.
Well, you haven't seen the
rest of the stuff I've got yet.
FRANK: Right.
Hopefully, Phil's not going be
pricing the rest of his stuff
like he's pricing this bike.
So how long have you
been on this property?
We've been on this
property for 45 years.
Really?
No kidding.
So when you bought this,
were any of these houses here
and stuff.
PHIL: It was completely--
that was a cattle ranch.
There were no trees.
MIKE: Really?
So you were, like, out of town
when you bought this thing.
We were out of town.
Ugh!
Here, need some help?
Hasn't been opened in a while.
MIKE: Whoa.
FRANK: So you're into wood?
MIKE: Yeah, you like the wood.
Hey, wood's expensive.
PHIL: Watch your step going up.
MIKE: All right, buddy.
Oh, wow.
PHIL: Just a lot of
architectural stuff,
the old wood from the barns.
When I started
collecting, I always
liked the looks of
things, and I thought,
well, I can bring
this one piece home,
maybe we'll use it in the house.
And then it was the next
piece, and then the next piece,
and it just got overwhelming.
And now I don't even
know what I've got.
Phil, man, you got
some doors, dude.
PHIL: A few.
MIKE: Oh, yeah.
Phil has an unbelievable
amount of doors here.
I mean, they're to my
left, they're to my right,
they're below me.
Oh, my gosh.
How many doors you got?
PHIL: Mm, few hundred of them.
Ooh, look at
those double doors.
You could tell that this guy did
a lot of architectural salvage.
I mean, guys that collect that
stuff have a different eye,
a very creative eye.
There's a lot of
work here, Phil.
They see it not just
in the application
that it was pulled away
from, but what it possibly
could be in a new life.
This mantle's cool.
Yeah.
MIKE: This mantle is from
the Arts and Crafts movement.
I like that.
The Arts and Crafts movement
was about getting the craftsmen
back into the process.
They wanted to show the
beauty of the furniture
and how it was made, and not
hide it behind embellishments.
How long have you
had this piece?
Do you remember
where you got it?
Well, I got it, probably,
in the early '70s.
It was out Grand River from
Detroit on the west side.
It's been in this barn
for over 40 years.
But if you were buying all
this architectural salvage
stuff, what were
your plans, overall?
What was the end result?
To use it.
I've got a lot of stuff, and
I always figured I'd maybe
strip it, and then sell it.
And now I should
be getting time,
because I'm getting old enough
that I can start working on it,
if I get room.
Would you sell it?
Sure.
MIKE: What do you got to
have for something like this?
$250.
Man, I think it's incredible.
I'd do the $250.
I love it.
I mean, the thing is
with Arts and Crafts
stuff, it's timeless.
Yeah.
MIKE: It really is.
It's truly timeless.
The great thing about
architectural salvage
is you can try to recreate
this kind of stuff,
but to have it be cost efficient
and to have it have the look,
you're never going to get there.
It's incredible.